i have definitely experimented with hair
colors over the years i mean i really
have i've tried every color there is
blonde
black
red
platinum blonde black tips you name it i
have loved playing
um and i was really excited when one of
our viewers um actually reached out to
us
and she herself was in need of a refresh
and
wanted you know a little assistance so i
would love for you to meet kelly
hi my name is kelly kitley and i'm a
chicago native with four children my
husband and i have been married for just
about 17 years and i am a
psychotherapist and author
my journey as a therapist and mother has
truly evolved having suffered from
various traumas in my childhood and
throughout my life i turned to alcohol
as a coping mechanism and really found
myself engaging in mommy drinking
culture and looking at my children
i knew i needed to do something
and change
i have been sober eight and a half years
and it is paralleled with my journey as
a therapist i mostly serve parents who
have had alcohol interrupt their lives
it has been so fulfilling and i love
that i can help others but it has truly
been quite draining
mostly during this pandemic we have all
needed more support than usual
and it has left me less time to do
things for myself and i've been feeling
a little burnt out
i work on the inner me but sometimes i
can't get to everything else and getting
my hair done is just not been top of the
priority list it requires a lot of time
and maintenance so i usually just throw
it up in this messy bun unzoom please
drew i'm in desperate need of a hair
refresh
funny
funny how uh something like that can
make such a drastic change in our lives
so we sent kelly out for a day
for herself
and give her a total hair rejuvenation
so please welcome the woman behind the
makeover you're about to witness and uh
the best colorist in the industry period
uh 20 years we've been working together
my dear friend tracy cunningham
[Music]
well you'll be happy to know that the
hair i have right now
is a gloss that tracy did as a base
color
uh several years ago and i just kept it
up and now it grew into this and people
are like i love your color i'm like it
is one simple base process here one here
and i've been growing it out for years
this is your color tracy
um we've teamed up with redkin
um for kelly's hair refresh and you're
an ambassador with them you have been
for so many years and um how amazing
that we could pick up the phone and call
the world's best expert tracy cunningham
so thank you for that thank you
what are some tips that you have for
someone who does want to do a complete
cover overhaul
okay first of all do your research
before you get to the hairdressers
and when you do
bring only one photo
because sometimes people bring in five
different photos they could be black and
white they could be you know three
different colored photos and we put them
all into our head and then we we just
you know try to give you one look
and it's not always perfect so just to
be on the same page bring in one photo
it's really helpful that's brilliant and
in your book true color you feature a
lot of brunette to blonde
transformations so what is your advice
to someone who wants to make that big
change
okay so there are two different kinds of
people in this world
there are people that want to go blonde
in a day
and there are people with patients that
will book
several appointments and they'll know
that each time they'll go lighter and
lighter the person that wants to go
light in a day just make sure that your
hair colorist has that time and make
sure
that you're ready to pay for
three full head highlights in one day
because people do get sticker shock
um okay well i would love to take a look
at kelly's look before so we can refresh
ourselves on what she was looking like
okay
shall we drum roll let's take a look at
her now kelly come on out please
[Applause]
wow
you're right
[Applause]
whoa
whoa
it's so beautiful
holy cow
thank you so much well how do you feel i
feel amazing it i have been petting
myself because my hair is so soft
and it's just manageable and i talked to
my family and they were like mom you
look gorgeous
over face time um and so it just i have
a little bit of a pep in my step and
that was even before i put on the dress
in the makeup
now
tracy i want to ask you
when you looked at kelly
what was your goal like what did you
look at and dissect and where did your
brain go to get to this hair color
when clients say i want to be blonder do
they lean here at the root i don't think
so the blonde should be around the frame
of your face
and the depth should be in
side the hair and the blonde should be
popping your your face and your skin
tone
so i i sent my friend kyle mahoney to
new york to do the transformation i knew
he would be the perfect person for it
because he actually was the one
who introduced me to shade cq
so
tyle and ice talked about it and we
thought she definitely needed some low
lights some shades eq lowlights added in
with some highlights
and
it just
it's it's so magical what bringing your
own natural hair color through
can do for the blonde it pops the blonde
and it makes the blonde feel blonder
and i think she looks so beautiful
with with the with her natural blonde it
looks beachy and beautiful
i absolutely love it i think she just
looks so amazing
so and all you need
all you need to do
is ask your stylist to do some redken
shades cute gloss
it's so easy it only takes 20 minutes
but you have to go to a professional
and you will
rock your own world and if you're
feeling like you need to pick me up
go to your stylist and they can give you
a shades eq gloss for a quick refresh
and give you a gorgeous shine the shades
eq really is my favorite line when it
comes to hair color mine too
it's literally giving me super powers
yeah no it's incredible okay kelly so
how do you feel and what is tomorrow
going to be like for you
well i have to go out on the town
somewhere because i feel fabulous but
and you are a beautiful person inside
and out and tracy i've known you for 20
years and i thank you so much for doing
this segment with us and being such a
good friend all over these amazing years
thank you so much
thank you so much
and tracy and kelly thank you and we
will be right back
[Music]